Welcome back everyone this will be my moon knight
black panther 2 video there's a bunch of easter
eggs they've had during the series that helped set
up that movie and what's going on with t'challa
inside the mcu so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
doctor strange 2 is coming out in theaters this
week we're doing a giveaway for imax tickets
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do with
the panther goddess in the mcu a warrior shaman
received a vision from the panther goddess bust
who led him to the heart-shaped app but there's
this huge tragedy with the passing of chadwick
boseman and marvel has to explain what happens
to black panther himself in the mcu after the
events of avengers end game during the events
of the movie because he was just fine at the end
of avengers end game he'd been reunited with his
family and looked like they were going to rebuild
wakanda because everybody had just come back this
will really bake your noodle but i think you're
just taking a little time out i'm afraid you're
actually quite dead but marvel has to explain
what's going to cause t'challa to die in a way
that requires them to eventually name a successor
black panther physically someone else will have
to take up the mantle because it's not like
marvel's gonna get rid of the concept of the black
panther in the mcu it's way too important to them
and it's way too important to the future of the
mcu during the recent episode of moon knight the
hippo goddess tarot explained the concept of the
afterlife just in general in how it's connected
to the idea of the multiverse in the mcu talking
directly about the black panther characters you'd
be surprised how many intersectional planes of
untethered consciousness exist like the ancestral
plane oh just gorgeous the way she explains it is
that when people die in the mcu even when gods die
they go to a different dimension that's based
on their own belief system or if they formed a
contract with another god like has happened with
moon knight so for example marc spector did not
believe in the egyptian enid before he met khonshu
but now that he knows kancho has a contract with
him when he dies he goes to the egyptian version
of the afterlife so the field of reads the duat
this place is an alternate dimension from the
ancestral plane the wakandans go there because
that's what they believe is their afterlife the
way they explain the afterlife in a scientific way
is that basically your untethered consciousness
exists they're separate from your body it's kind
of like existing on the astral plane they have all
those funny moments in the mcu with doctor strange
then the hulk and then spider-man being separated
from their bodies so you see their spirit kind of
flying around untethered from their physical body
that's kind of what it looks like when you exist
inside a version of the afterlife in order to
come back into your physical body into the mcu
a physical body has to exist for example that's
why it's so hard for people like odin or iron man
to come back into the mcu you could resurrect
them because their untethered consciousness
exists in the alternate dimensions based on
their belief system like odin's spirit the
odin force transferred to valhalla their version
the afterlife iron man was kind of an atheist he
didn't really believe in god so his consciousness
went to a different dimension you could bring his
consciousness back but you don't have his physical
body to put it back into you'd have to find
something to put his consciousness into because
the panther goddess is the sister of khonshu she's
also been a member of the eniate at different
times in the comics but in the mcu version
currently she's not a member during different
episodes when they're walking through the museum
or when they're walking past big murals with a
bunch of the different gods you see depictions
of her in the background in black panther is kind
of like the avatar of bast not in the exact same
way that moonite or arthur harrow or these other
avatars are connected to their gods black panther
in the previous black panthers typically just form
a contract with the panther goddess she doesn't
dominate their mind she doesn't order them all
the time to go around the world and execute her
will but for example if bast wanted something
done and told black panther to do it he would
be forced to do it it's just that most of the time
she leaves him to his own devices she just grants
him a portion of her power the same way that these
avatars have a portion of these other god's powers
recently during the episode of moon knight where
they have the meeting of the gods they said that
two members of the enid of their ruling council of
gods were missing they didn't know where they were
they couldn't locate them even with all their god
tier power that's meant to be an easter egg for
thor love and thunder and gore the god butcher's
mission going around killing all the gods as
in these members of the enid are missing because
gore was able to kill them without the other gods
seeing it happen or learning about his presence
yet the reason why he's able to do that with other
people finding out sooner or doing anything about
it is because the necro sword that he's using is
so powerful and because most of the gods are
pretty lazy and ignore what's going on with
the other gods each god typically only worries
about what's going on with their own following and
that's even only the gods that actually care about
what's happening in the mcu and there are very few
of those like everybody post your memes gore was
right most of the gods don't care about what's
going on with lower life forms so really it's the
god's own fault that goes around being able to
kill so many of them so fast without them doing
anything about it or finding out about it yet
bast isn't as bad as a lot of the other gods she
usually pretty pissed off anytime black panther
has to communicate with her directly or ask her
for more help than she's already giving them
but she does give him help when he asks for it
she's not as capricious as khonshu but she's
also not this warm fuzzy benevolent goddess
in the way they explain his connection to
the panther goddess his powers just in general
all the powers of the previous black panthers
is that they're basically a combination of the
minor mutations to their genome over the centuries
from consuming the heart-shaped herb for so long
everyone thinking about mutants coming into the
mcu just getting ready for it scarlet witch just
mess up the multiverse as bad as you want bring
as many mutants as you want into the mcu the
heart-shaped herb gives the black panthers a
little bit of a boost to their mind their body
like a super drug but it also helps facilitate
their connection to bast the panther goddess and
she grants them a portion of her supernatural
god tier power like the cosmic power that's where
most of his supernatural abilities come from
they didn't get into this a whole lot during
the black panther movie but they kind of hint
at it like he's not just king of wakanda he's
also called king of the dead he can communicate
with the spirits in a couple different ways he can
talk to previous black panthers and he can draw on
the experience of every black panther who has ever
worn the mantle and he doesn't need to travel into
the ancestral plane to do that like he doesn't
need to go into the afterlife they also show you
too that they use the heart-shaped herb as a sort
of transfer medium that allows him to transfer his
consciousness to the ancestral plane and then come
back him drawing power from the panther goddess is
another way that that happens but also on top of
that bast can resurrect him heal him in battle
just like moonite has a healing factor but like i
said bast doesn't use black panther as the finger
puppet that the other gods use their avatars as
is more of a contract between the two of them
at any given time the same is true for people
like umbaku who are part of the ape tribe they
worship different god just the ape god and it's
the same situation between him and their god he
gains a small portion of their power from his
connection to it and he's not a slave to it but
for example mbaku's ape god is not as powerful
as the panther goddess so umbaku isn't supposed
to be quite as powerful as black panther is we're
supposed to see bast on screen for the first time
during thor love and thunder as part of gore
the god butcher's quest to kill all the mcu gods
i don't think that they're going to let gore just
straight up kill bast even though if he were able
to almost kill her or trap her or mess with her
in some way it would cut off black panther's
connection to her and he lose some of his powers
some of his strength his healing abilities this is
where we get to the actual plot of black panther 2
i think that they'll use that plot to help explain
why in black panther 2 namor is probably going to
be able to kill black panther and they'll have him
be responsible for what happens to t'challa
they have this long rivalry in the comics
they're both kings of their respective nations
their nations exist pretty close to one another
and it looks like through all the easter eggs for
atlantis we've seen in the mcu so far there have
been several they've been setting up this
long running beef between the two of them
the first big namor atlantis easter egg was on
nick fury's map on iron man 2 just to show you
that it did exist in the mcu it's over here in
the atlantic ocean with this circle thus the name
atlantis then in avengers end game there was that
much bigger scene about the underwater earthquake
that okoye said they were just going to ignore
no big deal it's an underwater earthquake who
cares about it which probably wound up killing
a bunch of atlanteans reading on those tremors
it was a mild subduction under the african plate
do we have a visual how are we handling it net
it's an earthquake under the ocean we handle it
by not handling it during moon knight episode one
on the shops it read atlantis very clearly just
teasing it even more and now we have the whole
plot with the egyptian gods including bast who's
part of that pantheon even though she's not a
current member of the india that's just the ruling
council of the gods there are many other gods that
are part of this pantheon in what's happening in
thor love and thunder with all the gods getting
their asses handed to them by gore messing with
their connection to their avatars or anyone that
they're granting their power to as in the case of
black panther there's been a lot of rumors that
umbaku would be the one in the mcu to take over
the mantle of black panther and a lot of people
are asking how's that possible because he worships
the ape god and technically black panther's
family all of his ancestors were a member of the
panther tribe they worshiped the panther goddess
killmonger also burned the heart-shaped
herb during the first black panther movie
but umbaku or anyone else in wakanda who might
take up the mantle can form a pact with any of the
gods that they want and get the same basic power
set just from a different god really good example
of this is that during the ultimate storyline
black panther needs more power so he forms a
contract with the tiger god completely different
god fusing with its entire power to become this
cosmic level entity gaining enough power to kill
another even more powerful being that's formed
when two different cosmic entities combined to
form something that's powerful enough to kill
the living tribunal so the idea is that black
panther basically fuses with a different god to
gain even more power and become more powerful than
the living tribunal it was a very brief encounter
but it's just an example of the most op version of
black panther you'll ever see next to him wielding
the infinity gauntlet so even if something happens
to the panther goddess or something happened to
the heart-shaped herb they can still commune with
the gods just in a slightly different way and
gaining power of other gods not just the panther
goddess is a way that you recreate the powers of
black panther it's just they had to have all these
other series like moon knight and what's happening
in doctor strange 2, thor love and thunder to
explain how the mcu gods are different from cosmic
entities before they start doing a lot of this
crazier stuff black panther 2 is coming out this
november we'll probably get the first trailer
by the time thor love and thunder starts to hit
theaters so we'll learn more about what's actually
going on really soon but post all your theories in
the comments below my non-spoilery doctor strange
2 review will post next on tuesday morning make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel so
you don't miss that all my easter egg videos the
post credit scenes all those things will start
posting at the end of the week after the movie
comes out in my full moon knight finale video
we'll post on wednesday after they release it
congratulations christopher wood you're the
giveaway winner from my last big marvel video
please email me on the about page of my channel so
i can get your contact details everyone click here
for my full moon knight finale video i'll update
the link as soon as i post that and click here
for my doctor strange 2 non-spoilery review
i'll update the link as soon as i post that
as well thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!